[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 l'actualité locale et
régionale en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de ce mercredi
25 avril à la recherche de la fille
d'omar sy ou plutôt de celle qu'il
incarnera dans le prochain film avec
l'acteur trappistes un casting était
organisée aujourd'hui à trappes pour
trouver l'interprète du rôle de sophia
dont la nouvelle comédie de michel
hazanavicius
reportage à 10 ans il sillonne les
routes à vélo pour une action solidaire
gabin doit rejoindre brest samedi au
terme d'un périple de 6 117 km en 7
étapes une aventure au profit de
l'association vaincre la mucoviscidose
et nous étions sur la ligne de départ au
vélodrome national de saint-quentin et
puis retour à trappes à la fin de ce
journal la mairie organise pendant les
vacances un stage koh lanta inspiré de
l'émission télévisée
quarante jeunes participent à l'activité
qui met le sport agilité et endurance
une première dans la ville dans ce
journal nous reviendrons également avec
notre invité sidonie et banga sur le
cycle défi 2018 qui se déroulait la
semaine dernière dans le département
avant de développer ces titres est les
derniers chiffres du chômage ils sont
désormais publiés chaque trimestre et
des données négatives dans les yvelines
le chômage augmente de 0,9 pour cent
pour la catégorie à
dans le département le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi de cette catégorie
s'établit à 65 1210 au premier trimestre
2010 8
c'est la plus forte augmentation en ile
de france devant les hauts-de-seine le
chômage qui baisse par exemple dans le
val de marne où le val d'oise mercredi
jour de sortie au cinéma jour de casting
aussi à trappes l'équipe du prochain
film avec omar sy rechercher sa sofia
c'est le rôle de la fille du trappistes
dans la nouvelle comédie réalisée par
michel hazanavicius est mickaël millero
et camille lambert était sur place tu
écoutes
c'est très gentil d'accord mais je veux
pas voir quelqu'un à moi apparemment
enfin si tu veux tu pourrais premier
casting pour chérel le temps de quelques
minutes celle de viande sofia une enfant
drôle espiègle qui sera la fille d'omar
sy dans un nouveau film pourquoi tu peux
tu les vend son rôle bonjour avec omar
sy est vrai parce que j'aime bien faire
du cinéma
une ambition partagée par de nombreuses
petites filles âgées de 7 à 12 ans le
casting se déroulait à trappes ville
d'origine de l'acteur c'était bien on a
pris en photo - damien deguire un test
et ne regardent même sur sa chaîne depot
table et ça fait plaisir
on cherche le personnage ya des passages
test de dents dans le texte ya un moment
il n'y a que le personnage qui saura
dire comme il faut et c'est la vérité du
cac sisters et après l'accumulation
quand on a vu beaucoup de gens on
commence à en savoir plus son personnage
on sait qu elle est marrante on sait que
l on rigole bien avec son père
la comédie intitulée le prince oublier
sera réalisé par michel hazanavicius
oscarisée en 2012 pour the artist
ce nouveau film avec omar sy sera tourné
cet été 2010 8 en région parisienne
alors rappelez vous il a pris ses
fonctions lundi à versailles jean
jacques brot et le 19è préfet de
l'histoire des yvelines le premier
représentant l'état dans le département
a reçu la presse hier mardi pour évoquer
les sujets d'actualité ont été abordés
notamment les questions migratoires que
jean jacques brot connaît bien avant son
poste actuel il a été préfet chargé de
la mission coordination pour l'accueil
des réfugiés auprès du directeur général
des étrangers de france propos
recueillis par nicolas kirillovitch il y
a des
réalité française qu'il faut aborder
avec réalisme et respect et puis il ya
des souffrances
nous parlons là de réfugiés et de
demandeurs d'asile qui doivent être
aussi prises en compte avec les
tradition française d'accueil et de
respect du droit d'asile pour parler de
cela
après il ya d'autres réalités il ya des
mouvements migratoires très complexes
liés à la pauvreté de certains
continents entiers comme l'afrique ou
des guerres qui n'entre pas forcément
dans la question du droit d'asile mais
qui doit néanmoins être traités avec
humanité sept exactement nous
semble-t-il ce que le gouvernement
propose et c'est justement sur cette
question migratoire que le front
national des mines a interpellé le
préfet dans une lettre la fédération
demande à jean jacques brot a de se
saisir du dossier du centre de formation
pour les réfugiés a joué en josas
il doit entrer prochainement en fonction
un projet pour lequel les habitants de
la commune ont pas été consultée selon
le fn 78 suite de notre dossier à
présent sur le 50e anniversaire de mai
68 seconde partie à ce soir de
l'entretien avec gérard larcher à
l'époque l'actuel président du sénat est
âgé de 19 ans et est engagé chez les
jeunes gaullistes
il soutient alors la politique menée par
le président le président de la
république le charles de gaulle
il se confie à nicolas landry amical et
demi d'euros et marion ctaq pour les
moyens techniques
il ya un épisode comme remarque souvent
de mai 68 c'est un tournant c'est le 30
mai qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre
esprit de jeunes gaullistes
quand vous voyez que le général de
gaulle quitte la france on ne sait pas
où il va à ce moment là c'est seulement
après qu'on saura qu'il est allé en
allemagne à baden baden qu'est ce qui se
passe est ce que vous dit à un moment
donné vous avez douté du général de
gaulle à ce moment là d'abord grenelle
les accords sociaux
c'est sans doute là que je puise ma
passion pour le dialogue social et cette
passion pour le dialogue social
elle s'inscrit dans mon engagement des
mes 18 ans et elle va ensuite être
conforté
par toute la vie d'engagement politique
que j'ai autour des hôpitaux à proximité
avec philippe seguin mais grenelle c'est
quand même la voie du dialogue social
pour sortir d'une crise mais il ne
suffit pas des accords de grenelle on le
voit bien
24 je crois le général de gaulle
prononça premier discours à soria ya
désaccord et en même temps il ya cette
extraordinaire mouvement qu'on va
retrouver tente mais moi j'ai jamais
douté le général mais est ce que je me
suis posé des questions à ce moment là
non mais naturellement je n'étais pas à
paris mais j'ai fait partie de l'immense
cohorte de ceux qui ont soutenu le
général de gaulle justement un soutien
qui arrive après parce qu'à une
manifestation au moment où il revient
sur les champs elysées vous étiez ce
jour là non j'étais je préparais de
caucourt vétérinaire et j'étais à lille
et amiens
d'abord mais croyez moi il n'y a pas eu
qu'à paris
partout des hommes et des femmes ont
souhaité apporter au général de gaulle
le soutien est d'ailleurs noter que
général de gaulle va prendre en compte
les questions de la société
il va les prendre en compte mais pas
dans le désordre par en cédant à ce
cette épopée néo marxiste qui traverse
son pays ou néo libertaire naturellement
des éléments qui sont dessus sur
intéressant mais va y avoir la fameuse
dewa fort qui va organiser l'université
de manière différente va y avoir des
réformes conduites par le général de
gaulle très très vite dès la rentrée
2009 168 et des réformes qui vous
inspirent aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui adapté à une époque je crois
que depuis à l'université on a fait
l'autre grande réforme c'est valérie
pécresse qui l'a conduite avec nicolas
sarkozy c'est la réforme de l'autonomie
des universités entre temps il y avait
une formidable boom universitaire mais
il
c'est valérie pécresse avec nicolas
sarkozy qui veut conduire tous deux
cette deuxième transformation et puis on
est un pays différent
le taux de chômage en 68 c'est même pas
le terme texto frottement on est à moins
de 3%
cette plaie d'emploi et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une société différente
nous étions en 68 encore dans une france
industrielle la question ouvrière était
posée on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui y
compris dans ces périodes de tensions
qui ont eu lieu au mois d'avril et qui
sont des périodes de tension à la sncf
ou dans d'autres lieux
c'est peut-être des soubresauts d'une
france industrielle qui a un peu disparu
et j'allais dire d'ouvriers qui à
l'époque était encore nous étions une
grande puissance industrielle encore en
68 merci gérard larcher de nous avoir
accueillis ici sur vos terres de
rambouillet et dans ma maison de
rambouillet et dans ma permanence où je
continue à recevoir les citoyens et
direction un plaisir ou comme à chaque
vacances scolaires la municipalité
organisera des séances de
psychomotricité pour les moins de 3 ans
est la dernière en date se dérouler
aujourd'hui mercredi à la maison à des
familles la mosaïque objectif éveiller
les tout petits sur place il est un peu
plus grand c'est michael et me d'euros
[Musique]
comme souleymane deux ans ils sont une
dizaine d'enfants ce mercredi 25 avril à
participer à l'atelier psychomotricité
une séance organisée par la ville de
plaisir à chaque vacances scolaires
depuis plus de six ans objectif stimuler
l'éveil au niveau de la de la motricité
ça leur permet de prendre conscience de
leur corps d'être en relation avec
d'autres enfants d'autres adultes
et puis de valoriser leurs compétences
par l'intermédiaire donc les adultes qui
sont présents pour stimuler ses petits
âgés de 6 mois à 3 ans un espace d'une
vingtaine de mètres carrés a été aménagé
avec des ballons des tapis d'éveil
déjouer un trampoline
les enfants peuvent également se cacher
dans des tunnels sous l'oeil attentif
des deux professionnels de la petite
enfance qu'ont prise de risque est bien
maîtrisée bien évidemment il est hors de
question que les enfants se mettent en
danger mais on les laisse évoluer à leur
rythme c'est à dire que le concept est
aussi que les enfants prennent du
plaisir à être là à se retrouver entre
eux dans une ambiance tamisée la science
s'est terminée par un temps de
relaxation pour ces tout petits entourés
par leurs assistantes maternelles un
moment d'échangé bien méritée après
trois quarts d'heure d'efforts et on
reparlera tout à l'heure d'activités
pour les enfants pendant les vacances
attrape un parcours cycliste entre paris
et brest pour vaincre la mucoviscidose
l'initiative est louable et encore plus
si elle est menée par un enfant de dix
ans le jeune gabin et sur son vélo toute
la semaine pour rejoindre d'ici samedi
ce coin de bretagne une aventure
sportive et solidaire au profit de
l'association vaincre la mucoviscidose
et nicolas landry a suivi le départ
depuis à saint quentin en yvelines paris
brest 6 117 km 7 jours pour relier la
ville du finistère le périple du jeune
gamin a débuté dimanche 22 avril depuis
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une enceinte
que le passionné de vélo a pu visiter
avec son papa et son grand-père qui
l'accompagnent dans cette initiative
celle excité j'ai hâte et départir
parce que ça fait longtemps qu'on
prépare à mon grand père qui me parlait
souvent va de ses paris brest paris et
de sa et du coup j'ai essayé de faire du
vélo et j'ai bien c'est formidable de
l'accompagner de lui faire plaisir
puisqu'on a fait des randonnées en somme
tous les deux soit dans la région de
brest voit dans les alpes et c'est
toujours un plaisir d'être avec lui puis
l'entraîné de discuter de s'arrêter on
est assez admiratif de sa volonté qu'il
a alors il faut quand même savoir qu'on
va rester on va rouler tranquillement on
va pas on va pas rentrer dans les formes
que ça va très très bien se passer pour
lui une performance sportive pour cet
enfant de 10 ans une initiative surtout
solidaire pour aider la lutte contre la
mucoviscidose
une amie de la famille est touchée par
la maladie pendant son trajet gabin va
donc récolter des fonds pour une
association
le fait que ce soit un enfant je trouve
qui représente les valeurs de la lutte
contre la mucoviscidose c'est-à-dire
l'iden son souffle déjà un souffle
énorme et donne son dynamisme sa
persévérance son courage et donc je
trouve ça formidable qu'un enfant
après une halte par le club de
cyclotourisme de maurepas le trio de
cyclistes s'embarquer dans l'aventuré
un tracé qui empruntent celui du paris
brest paris randonneur
c'est un parcours exigeant ainsi 117 km
qui va traverser le perche la mayenne et
qui va finir sur la bretagne et avec pas
mal de dénivelé quand même direction
senonches dans l'eure et loir pour une
première étape d'une centaine de
kilomètres et gabin devrait arriver à
brest samedi 28 avril et le périple de
gamins se poursuit est bien pour le
moment depuis dimanche il est à passer
notamment par l'eure et loire la sarthe
et la mayenne de nombreuses rencontres
aujourd'hui mercredi le jeune cycliste
était était en route pour aider bazouges
en ille et vilaine
une quatrième étape d'environ 1,80 et km
c'était aussi une aventure à vélo le
deuxième cycle défi france se déroulait
la semaine dernière cinq jours de balade
dans les yvelines et paris auquel a
participé ont participé près de 30
jeunes pour en parler une invitée avec
moi plateau sidonie et manga mon sort
qui pousse oui vous êtes la
coordinatrice de ce cyclo france cyclo
défi france 2018 coordinatrice également
de l'association solidarité handicap
france cameroun déjà un premier bilan
sur cette édition 2010 8 comment ça
s'est passé
ou c'est un pari gagné il y en a pari
gagné j ai rempli les objectifs on avait
quatre sites à visiter à savoir le
vélodrome l'assemblée nationale
le louvre et puis la batellerie tout
ceci a été fait on va revenir dans le
programme en détail alors une ce n'est
pas qu'une balade à vélo de cinq jours y
amener des objectifs qu'elle qu'elle
était justement ces objectifs les
objectifs c'était débattre sur des
thèmes suivants les les monuments ou les
sites visités donc le lundi après le
vélodrome et l'assemblée nationale il
fallait débattre sur le thème de la
citoyenneté d'accord et l'assemblée
nationale est temps pour nous le lieu
par excellence pour parler de la
citoyenneté on a été très très bien reçu
je tiens le mentionner on a été très
bien reçue à l'assemblée nationale au
retour les jeunes ont débattu sur les
lois de tout ce qu'ils ont ramené tout
ce qui a été dit à l'assemblée
et puis on avait surtout le thème sur
l'environnement c'est découvrir les
yvelines qui est d'ailleurs une très
très très très belle une un très beau
département
on est allé de dusudaunord de nesta de
l'ouest à l'est coup de coeur agricole
en tout l'été à veut pas tout parce que
john normand également il ya de lure
banque est également mais simplement
d'un quand même visité beaucoup beaucoup
de terre un truc comme c'était pas mal
c'était très très bien dans les yvelines
qu'est ce qu'on a pu visiter on a visité
le circuit des pommes ou les jeunes ont
quand même fait un petit circuit et ce
qui m'intéressait beaucoup dans les
yvelines
c'est hormis ces terres agricoles les
jeunes sont allés du côté de mantes la
jolie où
visite et une demande la jolie et
surtout la collégiale et les canadiens
particulièrement repartent avec une
belle idée de la collégiale de juste
pour précisions il y avait aussi aux
côtés de français le vin décanat des
canadiens suisses des belges s'étaient
c'est un cyclo défi qui s'élargit qui
devient international qui pourrait même
peut-être je ne veux pas me prononcer
l'année prochaine s'est délocalisé
allait peut-être soit la côte d'azur sur
les côtes normandes parce qu'il faudrait
maintenant réaliser un autre défi qui
sera par exemple de faire 750 km en cinq
jours c'est pas encore bien défini mais
je pense qu'on ne sera pas très loin de
ce défi ces jeunes juste pour les
présenter venaient de quartiers
prioritaires
c'est des jeunes des quartiers
prioritaires ceux de saint laurent ceux
du canada et venait de saint laurent
c'est de belgique venait de comment ça
s'appelle une ville en belgique
peut-être que ça vous reviendra ça me
reviennent bien sûr c'est parce qu'ils
étaient deux ou trois qui venait de
trois villes de trois quartiers
différents
il y avait les suisses et puis l'année
prochaine on aura des allemands parce
que là on est en train de finaliser
encore une convention avec les allemands
on aura aussi les luxembourgeois qui
aurait dû venir cette année mais la
convention n'avait pas été finalisé
normalement donc s'internationalise
cette confiance analyse grâce à tv 78
parce que l'année dernière non il faut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont si
vous n'aviez pas été là l'année dernière
pour nous faire cette publicité en fait
donné cette visibilité
je pense que personne n'aurait été au
courant même de notre événement parce
que d'aucuns disaient non vous savez
manche le jeu je n'oublierai jamais
quelqu'un qui m'a dit vous les africains
vous avez de très bonnes idées mais vous
n'allez jamais jusqu'au bout et on a eu
la chance d'avoir tv 78 qui allait
jusqu'au bout qui a pu nous passer à
dans vos antennes pendant trois soirées
et c'était énorme pour nous ce qui nous
a permis d'aller au delà de au devant de
certaines personnes pour leur dire voilà
vous voyez nous on a fait ça sur les
origines du cycle déficit
vous avez piocher au canada ça se
faisait déjà au canada et vous l'avez
vous avez importé le concept on peut
dire en france c'est cela j'étais allé
un stage au canada et je suis
coordonnatrice de projet social
insertion ansaldi pour valider un
diplôme pour valider notre diplôme il
faut piloter le projet de boutons vous
alliez en amont comme en aval et moi
j'arrive au canada je trouve ce projet
steem à abobo est pourquoi je vais me
m'embêter aller chercher des trucs que
et j'ai la chance de tomber sur un
directeur de centre communautaire qui me
dit ok si c'est ce qu'on voulait faire
c'est très difficile faites le et puis
moi je vous soutiendrai
c'est ainsi que je participe dont ac
cyclo-défi canadien et je me l'approprié
va arriver en france je vais essayer de
leur faire leur façon et je suis arrivé
voilà on est un autre et deuxième
édition je pense que la troisième
édition sera plutôt un peu plus
difficile il nous reste un peu plus
d'une minute on a parlé des thèmes de
l'environnement également de la
citoyenneté y avait aussi le thème de la
solidarité nationale vérité on a pu
passer une une vidéo sur les migrants
s'étaient sos méditerranée on a pu
passer les jeunes ont pu importer leur
vision de la solidarité
comment est ce qu'il pourrait apporter
aussi leur aide à ces migrants et tout
et puis un nom il faut pas oublier le
thème de la culture
bien sûr la gamme de la culture on n'est
pas clôturée cette semaine pour clôturer
cette semaine on n'a pas clôturé oui
pourquoi pas on est allés au musée du
louvre où c'est surtout mes deux suisses
que j'avais qui était très très content
d'avoir vu d'avoir tous enfin pu voir la
joconde parce qu'on a raconté cette
histoire que je compte c'est la
photographie la plus surveillée au monde
et moi je connais un qui m'a dit je
n'imaginais même pas un jour que je
verrai la main je compte et ça quand je
sors du musée du louvre
je suis une femme il nous reste très peu
de temps un mot pour dire que ce cycle
des chivas poursuivre une édition au
canada cet été il ya quinze participants
qui à 15 participants seulement qu'ils
pourront y aller et
on commence le 29 et on termine le 4
donc ce que ceux qui ont été
sélectionnés pourront se rendre à québec
merci sydonia ben guérir sa mort est
avec nous parce que vous êtes la
coordinatrice de ce cyclo défi à 2018
qui se déroulait donc dans les yvelines
la semaine dernière une autre info vélo
et cette bonne nouvelle pour magny les
hameaux la commune ne sera bientôt
raccordé au reste de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en voix douce
le département des yvelines a confirmé à
la réalisation d'une piste cyclable
longeant la des 195 elle reliera le
hameau de villeneuve à manille village 1
km de tracé bidirectionnelle sécuriser
la décision ravit le maire bertrand au
lion même s'il reste encore prudent
écoutez le au micro de mélanie poker
c'est un soulagement et maintenant on
attend surtout la mise en place de ces
travaux puisque il y a toujours un
budget mais après il y a aussi des
appels d'offres et les travaux et on
sera vraiment soulagé le jour où on
pourra couper un ruban avec le
département pour aller faire une balade
à vélo pour tout simplement aller au
travail à vélo dans le reste de saint
quentin en yvelines est pas de date
encore arrêtée sur le démarrage de cette
opération même si un début des travaux
est envisagée pour cette année on
accueille sur ce plateau notre
journaliste au score michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir mon sens grégory alors
vous êtes venu nous parler golf plus
précisément de l'open de france qui se
tiendra du 28 juin au 1er juillet sur le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le plateau
de la compétition michael commence à se
dessiner
alors effectivement grégory et c'est
même un très beau plateau qui prend
forme ça vient de tomber aujourd'hui les
spectateurs pourront voir sur les greens
saint quentinois pour la deuxième année
consécutive le numéro quatre mondial
l'espagnol de 23 ans john drame récent
vainqueur de l'open d'espagne quatrième
du mythique masters d'augusta cette
année je vous propose de regarder un
extrait de ses dernières performances
[Musique]
pour psp go
joueur très puissant comme on l'a vu sur
cet extrait des caractéristiques qui
avait permis à john ram de terminer dans
le top 10 de l'open de france en 2017
il a déclaré vouloir faire encore mieux
à cette année grégory il espère surtout
réaliser un résultat pour montrer qu'il
a définie eu définitivement sa place
pour la prochaine ryder cup qui se
tiendra sur le même parcours que l'open
de france de golf en septembre prochain
mais john rabe ne sera pas la seule tête
d'affiche européenne mutel cette année à
l'open de france vienne peut vous
échapper un grégory angel drame aura
comme principal concurrent le vainqueur
de l'année dernière l'anglais de 27 ans
tommy afrik-foot 12e au classement
mondial 3e européen et tentera d'égaler
son compatriote britannique graeme
mcdowell vainqueur en 2013 et 2014 de
l'open de france plus vieux tournoi
continental avec 100 une édition
et les français dans tout ça est ce
qu'il y aura des têtes d'affiché
présente alors l'open de france attire à
chaque année des dizaines de français
même s'ils ne sont pas tous confirment
ils n'ont pas tous confirmé leur
présence les têtes affiches devraient
être présentes comme alexander levy
le golfeur de 27 ans a remporté le
week-end dernier le trophée hassan ii au
maroc le cinquième titre de sa carrière
qui lui permet d'intégrer le top 50
mondial et qui permettra peut-être à
celui que l'on surnomme le taureau de se
faire remarquer avant la ryder cup en
france
de son côté la coqueluche du public
français victor dubuisson sort à lui
forfait pour la compétition il doit être
éloigné des terrains pendant six mois
suite à une opération à l'oreille
interne à répétition à karim michael
c'est la ryder cup bien sûr en septembre
est ce que les américains fouleront les
les greens saint quentinois avant de
cette compétition c'est c'est le souhait
en tout cas du capitaine des états-unis
à jim furyk mais pas sûr que les joueurs
l'entendent de cette oreille tiger woods
ce qui revient en très grande forme sur
le circuit va snobé l'open de france
pour participer au tournoi de washington
sa dernière venue sur le golf national
remonte un tournoi juniors en 1994 lors
du championnat du monde amateur de leur
côté les nouvelles pépites américaine
justin thomass ou jordan spitz n'ont pas
encore communiqué sur leur participation
mais les organisateurs espèrent les voir
dans les yvelines évidemment la merci
michael est ce que vous avez l'âme d'un
aventurier toujours tu viens à ce
dernier sujet devrait vous intéresser en
cette deuxième semaine de vacances la
ville de trappes propose un stage koh
lanta toute la semaine qui mêle donc
sport agilité et jeux de mémoire comme
dans l'aventuré lévis
nicolas kirilow vide s'est rendu sur une
île celle du gymnase paul mallet attrape
regarder il y à l'équipe des jaunes
l'équipe des rouges mais aussi l'équipe
orange locaux lanta de trappes diffère
quelque peu de la version réelle mais
l'esprit est conservé avec notamment le
test redouté des aliments les yeux
bandés des noisettes
en tout quarante jeunes participent à ce
stage koh lanta pendant les vacances au
programme durant quatre jours sport
agilité endurance des activités variées
qui permettent de rassembler dans la
bonne humeur l'ensemble des enfants de
la ville d'habitude les stages c'était
donc un stage
de quatre jours soit cuisine soit que
sport basket foot activités manuelles
avec une sortie proposée à la fin de la
semaine
cette fois ci donc c'est tous les jeunes
qui sont mélangés toute la semaine sur 4
jours et qui s'affronteront donc
vendredi sur huit équipes pour pouvoir
relever le challenge du meilleur
aventurier
cette animation est une première à
trappes et elle séduit les enfants fans
pour la plupart de l'émission de tf1 une
émission qui avec 18 saisons au compteur
est beaucoup plus âgée que ces jeunes
aventuriers il veut subtil j'aime bien
regarder koh lanta du coup j'ai voulu
faire c'est quelque chose que je regarde
quand je suis chez ma grand mère mais
après leur projet n'est pas juste quand
je dors chez ma grand mère je regardais
et je la regardais et vendredi soir
c'est trop longtemps pour savoir qui
sera le meilleur aventurier de trappes
le rendez vous est fixé vendredi après
midi au stade gravaud pour prétendre au
titre certains ont encore beaucoup de
travail
c'est la fin de ce journal excellent de
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]